bonjour fabien gilot
merci beaucoup d'être en direct avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france pour parler
de de cette élection au niveau du
parlement pour élire le nouveau
président italien alors c'est pas un
rôle comme comme on a en france le
président italien a surtout un rôle
honorifique mais pourquoi est-ce
important cette élection
alors il ya plusieurs choses importantes
dans cette élection la première bien
entendu c'est l'importance quand même de
ce rôle parce que on va dire que le
président de la république italienne n'a
aucun rôle actif direct mais il est
quand même le gardien des institutions
le gardien de la constitution
c'est quand même un rôle donc important
est assez honorifique mais qui peut
avoir son importance réelle importance
en cas de crise du pouvoir c'est par
exemple le président de la république
qui pourrait anticiper ou dissoudre un
gouvernement anticipe et l'élection ce
qui est important aussi c'est de voir la
situation politique le panel politiques
italiens aujourd'hui savoir s'il va y
avoir des alliances ou pas c'est aussi à
un an des élections législatives qui
seront en 2023 de voir quelle est la
situation quelles sont les possibles
alliances et quels sont les potentiels
accords entre les différents partis mais
parce que le problème justement c'est
qu'aucun parti n'a de majorité claire
voilà tout à fait un on a déjà une
situation il ya beaucoup de partis
politiques différents beaucoup
d'alliances qui ont varié pendant les
quatre dernières années et en plus
aujourd'hui entre temps il ya eu encore
de de destruction d'implosion du
mouvement 5 étoiles et donc il ya un
groupe dit mixte donc des députés qui ne
sont plus affilié à un parti qu'ils sont
à peu près 10% du sénat et de
l'assemblée donc c'est à dire gros
volume 1 plus de 100 personnes qui sont
sans parti finalement et donc ils sont à
convaincre de voter pour un parti ou
pour l'autre c'est un grand défi en
général en plus la prochaine élection
législatives de l'année prochaine a va
avoir la réforme des députés y aura
beaucoup moins de députés qu'avant donc
aussi chaque député est un peu la
recherche d'un poste pour l'année
prochaine tandis que sergio matar est là
avait un rôle ce rôle d'unité dont vous
parlez et on sait l'italie on a eu
grandement besoin ces dernières années
un oui tout à fait c'était une figure
justement avec qui est toujours
recherché généralement pour la figure du
président de la république en italie
c'est à dire plutôt une personne qui
n'est pas forcément politique un ancien
juge un fondateur de l'association un
littéraire parfois on a parlé aussi de
l'historien par exemple pour cette
élection donc il faut une figure
vraiment très général mario draghi
potentiellement pourrait l'être mais si
mario draghi quitte le gouvernement il
va falloir trouver un remplaçant à mario
draghi ce qu'ivan elles ont compliqué la
tâche ça veut dire convoquer de
nouvelles élections derrière
potentiellement oui ça sera très
difficile dans ce qu'elle a de trouver
quelqu'un ou alors quelqu'un qui va
faire et l'intérim pendant un an mais ça
sera très compliqué beaucoup de partis
sont contre cette idée donc c'est pour
ça que même si mario draghi y est très
fortement apprécié on va dire fait
l'unanimité auprès de tous les partis
actuellement beaucoup de parties ne
veulent pas voter mario draghi parce
qu'il veut le laisser comme président du
conseil plus actif et continuer le
travail qui a été commencé il ya
maintenant plusieurs mois donc c'est
très difficile pour mario draghi est à
lui et il ya au cas d'autres candidats
aujourd'hui qui pourrait pour être élu
immédiatement alors il ya il ya eu un
temps silvio berlusconi qui a voulu
prétendre à la fonction présidentielle
il a jeté l'épongé pourquoi alors il ya
plusieurs raisons à cela alors c'est
aussi une mauvaise nouvelle on va dire
justement pour le dynamisme de cette
élection un directeur de journal italien
il hier disait que c'est l'élection
présidentielle la plus triste et la plus
ennuyeuse qu'il y ait eu pour les
italiens il ya peu de candidats peu de
personnes qui sortent silvio berlusconi
justement avait redynamiser un petit peu
cette élection il fallait trouver un
challenger à silvio berlusconi il a
décidé finalement de jeter l'épongé pour
plusieurs raisons premières tout
simplement physique médicale et des
hospitalisations hier on peut imaginer
qu'il ait quelques problèmes de santé il
est quand même plus très jeune et puis
également justement le centre-droit
n'est pas forcément si favorable que ça
ça près à son élection parce que ils
cherchent fait d'être une figure un peu
plus générales qui pourraient plus
plaire aussi justement au centre gauche
car silvio berlusconi est quand même
très clivant on va dire merci beaucoup
fabien gilot de nous avoir expliqué les
enjeux de cette présidentielle
en italie ce matin